[Musica]
che qualità avrà l'acqua di cui potremmo
disporre e dove la troveremo dove saremo
in grado di utilizzarla anche
quest'acqua pensate che nell'ultimo
rapporto e sta che è stato pubblicato da
lonu adesso nell'aprile del 2023
c'è scritto che circa il 55% sarà la
domanda globale di richiesta di acqua
per scopi
idropotabili e
[Musica]
avremo un incremento anche
della necessità di utilizzare
effettivamente quest'acqua e avremo una
popolazione che è passata dai 930
milioni nel 2016 a quelli che saranno i
2,4 miliardi nel 2050 popolazione che
avrà le sue difficoltà che avrà dovrà
interfacciarsi con quella che è la
scarsità idrica E pensate che negli
ultimi 40 anni
la richiesta l'utilizzo di acqua per
scopi troppotabili è aumentata dell'1%,
e sta continuando ad aumentare sta
continuando a crescere così tanto
e sembra un numero molto piccolo e
invece poi sono moltiplichiamo per tutti
gli anni è un numero veramente enorme e
questo per quale motivo che cosa sta
succedendo abbiamo un incremento
demografico abbiamo
un cambiamento nello sviluppo socio
economico e anche una cambiamento nei
modelli di consumo che noi abbiamo
Quindi questa
scarsità idrica purtroppo sta diventando
endemica e quindi dovremmo dovremmo
confrontarci con lei quotidianamente
costantemente nel nostro prossimo futuro
e anche perché non abbiamo a che fare
soltanto con quello che viene chiamato
uno shortnin idrico ma anche poi con un
depauperamento della qualità a causa
dell'inquinamento e anche naturalmente a
causa di quelli che sono i cambiamenti
climatici che stanno provocando
sostanzialmente anche una
siccità stagionale Che cosa significa
che in certi periodi dell'anno avremo a
che fare con una prolungata siccità
magari che è quello che è successo a noi
anche nella nostra nella nostra Italia e
quello che
potrà succedere in tutti i paesi in cui
c'è attualmente anche abbondanza d'acqua
non soltanto nei paesi come ad esempio
nel Medio Oriente o
in Africa dove stanno già vivendo questa
questa criticità
E pensate che
adesso con l'aumento delle delle
temperature con i cambiamenti climatici
avremo
la necessità di continuare a conoscere e
ad investigare quello che sono le nostre
attività maggiori e per cercare di
capire con che cosa fa che cosa fare e
nella nostra regione che cosa sta
succedendo
pensate che nel nord est della nostra
regione nella zona dei Muse ad esempio
Piovono circa 3.000 mm di acqua ogni
anno 3000 mm quanto sono sono tre metri
ci sono state delle punte anche negli
anni scorsi di circa 5.000 mm sono 5
metri di acqua ogni anno è Tanta è
tantissima però nonostante questo
Avremo comunque e vivremo Comunque le
nostre criticità
ma
dove la troviamo noi effettivamente
quest'acqua e quale acqua utilizziamo
poi noi Soprattutto per bere mi piace mi
piaceva l'idea di mostrarvi un'immagine
della nostra regione e vedete ci sono
tutti quei puntini colorati che
rappresentano i Pozzi per acqua in
Italia pensate che
l'80-4% circa dei prelievi a scopido
potabili
viene realizzato proprio all'interno
utilizzando dei pozzi oppure i prelievi
vengono realizzati sulle sorgenti
soltanto il 16% invece è quello che
proviene dalle acque superficiali come
ad esempio dei Laghi e dei fiumi e che
sono quelle che sostanzialmente sono
maggiormente in crisi adesso
Però anche in Friuli Venezia Giulia il
prende lo stesso Sì assolutamente sì lo
vediamo nella nostra regione lo vediamo
qui ci sono circa
55.000 Pozzi
dei quali noi preleviamo le risorse
idriche e vedete che hanno una
distribuzione un po' particolare li
vediamo solo nella zona sud della nostra
della nostra regione Per quale motivo
semplicemente perché la nostra regione è
geologicamente diversa
idrogeologicamente diversa nel senso che
è suddivisa nella zona Montana in quella
che è la zona dell'alta pianura e nella
zona della Bassa pianura lo vediamo qui
e in alta pianura in bassa pianura sono
sostanzialmente
raccolte le acque che noi attingiamo per
riuscire ad avere un'ottima risorsa
idrica da poter bere
abbiamo la zona dell'alta pianura che è
quasi una vasca da bagno Pensate ad una
vasca da bagno è un contenitore
sostanzialmente il dentro cui c'è
l'acqua formato da ghiai e da sabbia
Quindi da sedimenti molto molto
grossolani sciolti e poi abbiamo la zona
della Bassa pianura che è un sistema di
acquiferi e confinati sovrapposti uno
sopra l'altro come se fosse
sostanzialmente una torta e da questi
sistemi di acquiferi noi siamo in grado
di assorbire l'acqua che ci serve per le
nostre necessità quotidiane
E come lo facciamo lo facciamo
attraverso quei 55.000 Pozzi che abbiamo
visto E come facciamo a capire però se
ne abbiamo abbastanza di acqua Lo
capiamo perché possiamo Monitorare le
variazioni dei livelli di queste di
questi acquifere quando noi
analizziamo le acque se andiamo ad
analizzare delle serie storiche la
Regione ci ha messo a disposizione una
rete di monitoraggio importante
possiamo capire che c'è un
depauperamento
qualitativo della risorsa Che cosa
significa significa che le falde si
stanno abbassando che i livelli si
stanno abbassando e che la pressione
degli acquiferi confinati sta diminuendo
e di quanto si abbassano si abbassano di
pochi centimetri nella zona della fascia
delle Risorgive mentre si abbassano di
più di qualche metro proseguendo verso
nord e la pressione nella zona della
Bassa pianura Che cosa le sta succedendo
e vi ricordate l'anno scorso cosa è
successo proprio qui nella zona del
pordenonese le pompe non buttavano più
ad un certo punto è stato necessario
riuscire a raggiungere le famiglie
grazie alle autobotti Per quale motivo
perché i livelli sono scesi c'era meno
pressione perché la ricarica dei sistemi
di Acufeni Della Bassa pianura è legata
a quelli che sono i sistemi da qui per i
presenti nell'al cucitura è tutto un
sistema comunicante È come se vivessimo
in un condominio di cinque piani o
qualche piano in più o qualche piano in
meno e pensate che voi siete uno dei
condomini poi c'è un altro un altro
condomino e questo usa ad esempio lui
vive a piano terra al giardino e può
usare l'acqua per bagnare il suo
giardino per farsi
per lavare la macchina fare
l'idromassaggio Magari tutte le sere
buttando Poi l'acqua e ad un certo punto
se il serbatoio che avete a disposizione
è lo stesso ad un certo punto per voi la
disponibilità non ci sarà più
e quindi nella nostra regione è la
stessa identica cosa Se chi è nella zona
della Bassa pianura usa male l'acqua la
usa in maniera irresponsabile per chi
poi è negli altri appartamenti
quest'acqua ad un certo punto non ci
sarà più
E allora Che cosa che cosa si deve fare
che cosa si può fare anche perché
nel mondo il quantitativo di acqua è
limitato e quindi che cosa possiamo fare
noi in primis per poter in qualche modo
rendere sostenibile quello che sarà la
nostra
la nostra vita futura e quella dei
nostri figli
ci sono tante opzioni nel senso che è
possibile agire a livello globale quindi
A livello mondiale a livello
sovranazionale a livello magari locale
ma anche noi stessi possiamo decisamente
essere i primi a fare qualcosa con delle
piccole azioni che però ci permettono
comunque di poter veramente incidere sul
sistema perché semplicemente perché
siamo tanti e se ciascuno di noi fa la
sua piccola cosa allora saremo
assolutamente in grado di adattarci a
quello che succederà e quali sono queste
cose beh a livello globale abbiamo
l'accordo di Parigi del 2015 quindi gli
stati stanno lavorando a livello locale
e a livello nazionale Esistono le
direttive europee e pian piano vi via
tutti stanno cercando di adattarsi a
quelle che sono le direttive europee e
Pensate ad esempio alle reti
acquedottistiche si sta cercando in
qualche modo con Grazie a tutti i
contributi europei e nazionali di
efficientare le reti le reti idriche
abbiamo pensato più del 40% di perdite
nelle reti acquedottistiche
e poi che cosa si può fare Beh anche il
comparto Agrario in senso in senso lato
sta decisamente facendo molte cose per
riuscire a ad avere una garanzia Futura
di sopravvivenza anche delle
coltivazioni quindi si stanno cambiando
progressivamente i sistemi di
irrigazione ma anche sostanzialmente si
sta prevedendo di realizzare dei piccoli
invasi quindi dei piccoli laghetti che
permettono di accumulare le acque quando
quando piove e quindi quando poi è per
poterle poi utilizzare in un secondo
tempo e a livello personale che cosa
possiamo fare
Beh tutti voi vi lavate sicuramente
tutti voi fate la vasca Chi fa la vasca
in quanti siete Che fate la vasca alzate
la mano
Ah pochi Bene bravi virtuosi eh La
maggior parte evidentemente fanno la
doccia quindi farsi la doccia una doccia
breve invece che la vasca è già un bel
punto di partenza usare asciugatrice e
asciugatrice Si mi sbaglio usare la
lavatrice e usare la lavastoviglie a
pieno carico sicuramente ci fa
risparmiare dell'acqua pensate che
quando ci laviamo i denti se non
chiudiamo il rubinetto sprechiamo circa
una trentina di litri di acqua al giorno
moltiplicatevi moltiplicatevi per i
giorni che abbiamo a disposizione in un
anno moltiplicateli per gli anni in cui
vive ciascuno di noi moltiplicatevi per
il numero di persone che siamo Quanti
litri d'acqua sono sono risparmiati
e quindi
riassumendo Che cosa che cosa succederà
e succederà che di acqua ne avremo
comunque purtroppo di meno anche noi che
siamo e viviamo in un posto in cui
l'acqua c'è ed è abbondante e la sua
qualità anche sarà purtroppo sempre
peggiore per quale motivo perché la
stiamo inquinando e l'acqua che noi
stiamo utilizzando che quella anche
profonda circa 200 metri di profondità
Guardate Guardate sulla slide ha un'età
di circa 20.000 anni quindi significa
che se noi smettessimo di far piovere ci
vorrebbero 20.000 anni per poter
ricaricare quelle falde e quindi quello
che dobbiamo fare è cercare di non
sprecare questa risorsa preziosissima
anche magari evitando di fare la doccia
di fare la vasca e semplicemente di
farci una doccia veloce Grazie
[Applauso]